the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
we're proud that we're making an
investment in our kids
on politics now the legislative session
is over we look at the state's biggest
boost to education funding
and the new mining tax deal obviously
what we are trying to do is make sure
that it is as easy as possible for
people to get registered to vote
nevada expands mail-in voting and tries
to leap frog to the front of the primary
line
we'll break down all the new election
laws and rules plus nevada getting legal
pot lounges
just how soon tourists will have a place
to smoke their marijuana
from 8 news now this is politics now
i moved at the senate of the 81st
session
of the senate of the legislature of the
state of nevada adjourn
sinai die
[Applause]
there it is after 120 days and a last
minute flurry of votes the 2021
legislative session is over
we thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler now the
itunes david charns the only local tv
reporter here from southern nevada
to go up to carson city for the end of
the session and david you're here to
kind of sort it all out there's a lot
that happened here
it was quite the end and the run-up to
midnight there and with control
of both houses democrats were able to
really get large chunks of their agenda
passed that means
mail-in voting that public health
insurance option and marijuana lounges
well all is calm now outside of the
nevada legislature but
in true nevada style lawmakers went up
right until that deadline first session
of the nevada legislature is adjourned
minutes before midnight tuesday the
senate and assembly called an end to
their four-month session
one that brought changes to elections
policing and taxes
we help the small businesses we help the
community we help
students we put money towards education
it was never
happened before that money after
lawmakers scrambled to reach a deal
on taxing the mining industry the
bipartisan plan is expected to bring
about 80 million dollars into education
every year mining had a gun to their
heads don't kid yourself so
i don't really even have a problem with
mining pay a reasonable
additional amount but they've got to be
exceptionally careful nevada will also
move toward voting in primaries instead
of caucuses
assembly speaker jason fryerson says
that proposal
and expanded mail-in voting only makes
the democratic process
easier with added protections for
signature verification
and the days ballots can be accepted we
believe that as a constitutional right
people should have every option to fully
participate now you
allow mail-in ballots to come in a
little later and so it's
days almost a week until you get your
election results
and people automatically start to begin
to get suspicious decriminalizing
traffic stops
creating a public health insurance
option and a new structure to regulate
marijuana lounges there's just a lot
good things that happen and i'm proud of
them we're going to take the bills one
at a time the governor has 10 days to
either sign a bill
veto it or let it become law without his
signature
he tells me what started as a big
unknown with the coronavirus pandemic
has ended with a feeling of hope and
confidence
all right so here are some more details
on that mining tax it's an excise tax
that will be 0.8 percent for mines that
make
less than 20 million dollars a year
sites that make
more than that more than 20 million
dollars a year they get bumped up to 1.1
there are currently 103 mines of all
sizes here in nevada
here's how democrats and republicans
reacted to the measure
nevada when our economy is based on all
gaming
we don't survive and so we have to
diversify our economy we have to do more
with revenue
and we need to have a broader
conversation about revenue this is the
beginning of that conversation this is a
good start
in a statement the chair of the nevada
republican party michael mcdonald said
quote
ab-495 much like any new tax introduced
in nevada is a clear violation of the
party's platform the republican party's
platform
and an unnecessary solution to a problem
brought by the democrats inability to
lead
and govern so david that mining tax it's
part of nearly
a billion dollars extra dollars that
went to public education funding this
session
yeah a lot of talk about education this
session and yeah in addition to that
there's actually about a half
billion more dollars added to that going
to that base
per student funding and then yet another
200 million dollars in federal funding
coronavirus stimulus funding that will
add things like learning loss and work
on child literacy so you can probably
call this the biggest
investment in k-12 education that nevada
has made so far
now there were also two ballot
initiatives that teachers unions
proposed
before the pandemic one was a gaming tax
there was also a sales tax
what was the future for those well there
actually was a separate bill that would
let them
withdraw those two ballot initiatives so
the ccca
is expected to do that so those won't be
on the table
all right well nevada may be the second
state to offer a public option for
health care
by the time this passed ab420 it had
been amended several times
washington state was the first to offer
a public option for health care
nevada's version requires that insurers
that bid to provide coverage for people
under medicaid
must also offer a public option plan
they'll be similar to other plans
offered by the state exchange but with a
five percent markdown
but it's not going to take effect for a
while now they're not going to have to
offer that option until
2026. also from the legislative session
legal places to smoke pot the bill
creating consumption lounges has
passed there will be licenses for
existing businesses
and 20 independent ones as well david
this has been an ongoing discussion here
in nevada especially in southern nevada
with all the resort corridors
how long before these pot lounges are
awesome to start opening up well
first of all the governor has to sign it
it's going to take a couple of months
once he does sign it we do expect him to
do that the cannabis compliance board
will
still have to set up all the rules and
regulations on how you're going to get a
license for that so it's going to take a
while before businesses then apply for
them
they have to be approved open up do
they'll do the whole thing you've seen
the song and dance before
may not be very soon john what other
maybe a major marijuana legislation did
pass up in carson city well
the bill to allow curbside pickup that a
lot of folks had wanted during the
pandemic
also passed and that started right away
so you can do that now
the other major one that would have
allowed pop-up tents at events and
festivals though
did not pass and we profiled that issue
on politics now a couple of weeks ago as
well
a lot of marijuana lobbyists up in
carson city by the way this session
well meantime new sweeping clean energy
legislation accelerates a huge
transmission project and puts in more
electric charging stations we're talking
about green link nevada it's a two
billion dollar project that basically
links
the entire state with two transmission
lines every energy envy energy that is
has to finish it by 2029 that's eight
years from now
it requires a plan from nv energy to
spend 100 million dollars on new
electric vehicle charging stations all
across the state
and it also takes the state's renewable
energy portfolio standard which we've
told you about it's that 50 percent by
2030 even further
utilities now have to come up with a
plan to see an 80 percent reduction
in the 2005 carbon dioxide emission
levels by then
nv energy told us senate bill 448 will
transform nevada's clean energy
landscape
create thousands of good paying jobs and
ensure nevada's underserved and low
income communities benefit from this
energy transformation well maybe you
have one of these plates the classic car
loophole has been closed
now in order to get one of the plates
which exempts cars from a smog check
people will have to
have classic car insurance maybe you
drive one of those
2011 law just to find classic cars
as any car that's over a certain age
which is why you've seen so many beat up
ones
on the road with those classic car
plates john
all right well let's talk about some
bills that did not pass the legislative
session
we previously told you about a measure
to try and end the death penalty that
failed to pass it's a bill from senate
majority leader nicole cannizzaro it
would have essentially
also made casinos gun free zones that
also didn't pass
that was pushed by mgm resorts a law
that would have made it a
lat law rather would have made it a
crime to ignore signs on any business
with signs that say no guns allowed
however
it had several stipulations including a
warning before staff could call police
i obviously brought that legislation
because i do think that we have to take
gun violence here in this state
seriously
i definitely believe that we should have
tools to be able to enforce that
we have done that on a number of
different occasions here in the in this
state and certainly while i've been in
this building
with background checks to make sure that
domestic abusers don't have access to
guns
with making sure that our libraries our
government buildings
and other facilities like education
facilities can
ensure the safety of those individuals
there and this is no different from that
so david as this went through the
legislative process there was an unusual
group of opposition to it a lot of
different people were unopposed
yeah something we don't normally see
there was the opposition from republican
gun rights groups like the nevada
firearms coalition which
we would expect you know in the in this
this day and age but also
progressive groups like battleborn
progress and even the aclu
even pro-gun control groups like the
giffords group
had objections to this now those
objections were different than what
republicans objected to but effectively
killed this whole thing if both sides
are against it it's not going to go too
far up in carson city though
it did come pretty close to passing yeah
and it's sort of we
it's different this time usually we see
things close in the assembly or passed
out the assembly this time it passed the
senate
11 to 10 which is more than uh the
majority
um the the republican voted for that but
though it did not make it out of the
assembly all right well another thing
that my i-team colleague vanessa murphy
covered would have created a licensing
commission for midwives this is assembly
bill 387
it required a two-thirds vote because
there were licensing fees for midwives
associated with this
nevada is the only state in the west
that does not require
midwives to be licensed you can go watch
vanessa's story right now on our website
a newsnow.com
so this did pass out the assembly but
then it missed passing in the senate by
just one vote
13 to eight and it wasn't along any part
of the lines either john
and you mentioned vanessa our own
vanessa murphy covered this issue deeply
nevada now will still be the only state
without the licensing for midwives we
have all those stories stolen eight
newsnow dot com though
interesting story interesting topic for
sure well i did ask governor sisalak if
he had any
favorite bills you know there's so many
this is what he said
there's a lot of them that are favorites
to me i mean the
the mining taxes is incredible it's huge
like i said my team works so hard to get
that across the finish line i mean
fixing dieter is big to me it's
important there's so many i mean there's
money that went towards medical school
there's just a lot the good things that
a long legislative session is over good
coverage up in carson city hope you
enjoyed your first session up there
uh next on politics now we do have more
believe it or not on the legislative
session
we're going to dig into the bill making
nevada the first to hold a presidential
primary
we have reaction from new hampshire and
iowa plus seligman tom roberts says he
plans to run for
sheriff we'll talk about that
welcome back to politics now
i think the future is as many pundits
have said
that we'll become the first state to
have a primary
because iowa and new hampshire have not
been very
representative of what happens in the
country and that was former senator
harry reid the democrat talking to us
after
last year's democratic caucus here his
push to have nevada be the first
state to vote on the presidential race
is moving forward
the primaries the nevada legislature
passed a bill at the session
that makes the caucus a primary in
nevada and
leapfrogs nevada to first in the session
of primaries now
in opposition to the bill republican
party chairman michael mcdonald released
this statement saying that
this measure is quote trying to play
chicken with primary dates
and that he says it's not a battle that
we will win now the states in front of
nevada
on the primary calendar caucus calendar
in one regard
is iowa and new hampshire here is a
response from new hampshire's
they've given every indication they
would fight this this is from the
democratic party chairman who says
we have successfully defended the
primary for decades and believe that we
have a strong argument
for new hampshire to retain its place at
the beginning of the queue
iowa's democratic party chairman says
it's working to ensure the state has a
crucial voice in the nominating process
as well david charns so here's the
statement by the way from
the iowa chairman david charns spoke
with steve sebelius from the review
journal and i-8 news now
about the primary bill while they were
in carson city
we're once again joined here by 8 news
now political analyst steve sebelius
also
a politics and government editor with
the review journal steve a lot happened
particularly in the late hours last
night going all the way up until that
midnight deadline but i want to talk
about
the bills that have the most effect for
most of us most of us watching at home
which is those election bills
yeah the during the pandemic for the
first time the majority of nevadans
voted by mail
they received the mail ballot by a
special action in the legislature well
they made that permanent so now
all active registered voters will
receive a ballot in the mail
unless you opt out and choose say i want
to go and vote in person
and i don't want that mail ballot you
will get a ballot in the mail
a lot of people found it very convenient
it was uh it was
easy to to vote at home especially with
the long ballot that we had
when they were like two pages right with
everybody right and back
right and and you know something that's
probably going to have national
implications is going to have national
implications not a probable is the
switch to primaries
and possibly being the first now of
course iowa has the caucuses
new hampshire has primaries they set
their dates
this bill would make it the first
tuesday in february
could we actually be the first in the
nation primary we could
although new hampshire state law allows
the secretary of state of new hampshire
to set
their primary whenever he wants to to
make sure that it's first in the nation
so they could still leapfrog us
there's a lot of negotiations i think
that are going to have to be worked out
between the political parties as to who
actually goes first
whether we you know continue with the
iowa caucus first
but one thing is certain nevada's caucus
is a thing of the past there will be no
more caucuses you'll go to the polls
you'll vote for your choice for
president the way you vote in any other
election and that will happen once every
four years so the governor now has
10 days to decide what he's going to
sign because you know that's how
remember that uh i forget what it is the
let's have
the make a bill song you know the school
of rock yes so
um he has to sign this for for anything
to become law he can veto it it doesn't
become law
or he can just let it become law on its
own anything you see that these folks
passed
that you think he's going to
automatically veto we asked him last
night and
he wasn't so forthcoming yet yeah i
don't
see a lot of veto potential in in the
bills that that he signed
democratic house democratic senate sends
bills over there i think they're going
to be pretty much aligned with what the
governor wants
and he has signaled i'm sure behind the
scenes what he would like to see what he
would not like to see
so i don't think there'll be a lot of
vetoes all right well we'll see what
happens in the next couple of days steve
thanks so much for your insight
three days here we've been on the ground
in carson city and we are in carson city
i'm david charns eight news now guys
back to you
as of the taping of this program so far
governor sysolak has not used a veto and
if he doesn't use one at all
it would be the first session since
governor kenny gwynne back in 2003 who
also didn't use one at the time
next on politics now we're going to sort
out who's running for what in 2022
a look at the names lining up for clark
county sheriff and henderson mayor
plus this republican legislators around
the country are trying to
ban the critical race theory from public
school classrooms
coming up we'll take a look
8 news now
[Music]
welcome back henderson city councilwoman
michelle romero plans to run for mayor
current mayor deborah march is term
limited in 2022.
romero made the announcement on saturday
last saturday
this position is nonpartisan but romero
is a republican
she was just reelected in 2019 her city
council term ends in 2025.
also looking ahead to the next session
here we've got assemblyman tom roberts
who tells politics now
he plans to run for sheriff i did
34 years in law enforcement i retired
to come up here and work in the
legislature i found that i still miss
law enforcement i like it just like here
i like serving my community
but i really believe that i could make a
difference at metro if i went back
and there's an opportunity with the
sheriff running for governor
and i think i'm going to jump into the
race and i think the voters will be
happy with what they get
my message is look i want to do what's
best
for the citizens of las vegas
you know crime i think is always in the
back of people's minds but also police
the delivery of police services
is i think we can do we do a good job at
metro i think we can always
do better i think we need to work with
the community close
to ensure that we're policing the way
they want to
and i think metro does a pretty good job
but i'd like to take it to the next step
so far roberts is the only candidate
who's declared the intention to run for
sheriff sheriff lombardo
is intending to run for governor
republican state legislatures across the
country have been trying to ban
something called critical race theory
from public schools
republican lawmakers are attempting to
ban what they claim
critical race theory teaches students
proponents
say learning about historical injustices
can be uncomfortable
that whites are an oppressor race and
other identity groups are oppressed
i've never heard an educator saying
white people are inherently bad
joining us now from washington is
alexander limon
alex let's talk first what exactly is
critical race theory
critical race theory is something that
is not new it's actually a concept
that's been around for decades i believe
around
40 years or so and some of the academic
experts who study it describe it as a
theory where you're
encouraged to take a critical lens to
examine
u.s history and the role that racism has
played in our country's history
and that role that it still continues to
play in
our laws in our society and how that
racism
is embedded in everyday life and so it
encourages people to use critical
thinking and again that critical lens
so that's the widely academic use
definition for it but in recent months
critical race theory has had a big
spotlight on it because
republican lawmakers both state
lawmakers and also
here on capitol hill have focused in on
this
issue claiming that it actually teaches
students to feel guilty about being
white that it teaches students that
the white race is an oppressor race and
other races
are the victims and have been victimized
and they claim that it's a very
divisive theory that pits
races against each other and is divisive
for the country and so republican
lawmakers and state legislatures around
the country
like in oklahoma for example have either
already or are in the process of trying
to
ban it from being taught in public
schools
well how frequently is this taught in
schools
funny you should ask because it's not
you know many
school districts around the country have
been kind of put
in the spotlight and accused of teaching
critical race theory
and what all of these school districts
have said is that they do not actually
teach it this is not a theory
that is used in public k through 12
schools
it is mostly a theory that is used in
academic
higher learning circles you know in
colleges universities people getting
their phds for example in in
areas that are related related to race
and policy
that was alex limon from washington
most watched evening and late news
you're watching politics now
looking ahead boulder city has a
municipal election coming up june 15th
and early voting is already underway
down there runs till june 11th
there's an open city council seat and
two ballot initiatives
the first is to see if people want to
spend seven million dollars on a new
swimming pool
the second is whether or not the city
should sell land
to fund that project we have information
on this for you
at 8newsnow.com we thank you for
watching politics now we'll see you
right back here next week
you